el escándalo del vacuna gate le terminó
cobrando la factura al expresidente de
martinis carr a la inhabilitación del
congreso de perú por 10 años de toda la
función pública le impide recibir las
credenciales de congresista vizcarra
según el conteo oficial fue electo como
el congresista más votado en lima en las
elecciones generales que se realizaron
este domingo en perú la sanción del
parlamento fue respaldada con 86 votos
de los legisladores quienes consideran
que martín vizcarra violó la
constitución y aprovechó su cargo como
presidente para vacunarse de forma
irregular con dosis de la vacuna contra
el jove y 19 el mayor agravante para los
legisladores radica en que usó el poder
para direccionar la vacunación
clandestina también para su esposa y su
hermano vizcarra tenía previsto ser
congresista en el período 2021 2026 y
luego postular a la presidencia del perú
la inhabilitación bloquea su futuro
político sin embargo el exgobernante
anuncia que apelará la sanción del
parlamento con un recurso de amparo ante
la justicia peruana y también señaló que
emprenderá acciones legales en
tribunales internacionales
el congreso de perú también
inhabilitó a las exministras pilar
mazzetti elisabeth act por 8 años y un
año respectivamente